purpose is always idealized right like
as I said before I imagine a world in
which right I know I'm not going to get
there like when Martin Luther King said
I have a dream like one day little black
children will hold hands on the
playground with little white children
right like all of these things they're
all striving
and the the Milestones that we pass make
us feel like we're making progress and
that's why metrics are really important
and Milestones are really important and
the most important thing is context
there's nothing wrong with quarterly
numbers and annual numbers the only
question I would ask is to what end
to what end like you know I was talking
to a young entrepreneur last night and
she's looking for investment and one of
her potential investors said
um how long is it going to take you to
hit a hundred million dollar revenues
and I said don't take that person's
investment
show me one article one I just need one
show me one article on hbr one study I
don't care that demonstrates that hyper
growth or high speed growth is good for
is good for the company on any level
the answer is there are none
the pressure comes from that person
trying to achieve their financial goals
so they put pressure on you to make your
short-term goals right and so
um and so there's nothing wrong with
goals as long as we understand the
context and the purpose of that goal
right
um I like to think of money like fuel
right and a car is the company and the
purpose is the destination right and if
money is fuel it makes the car go you
absolutely have to money to make the
company go you have to have you have to
there is no dreaming big if you have no
fuel you can have the most beautiful car
in the world
and yet if you've got no fuel it's
pointless but we don't own a car to buy
fuel
right we don't own we don't have
companies simply for the money
right it's the destination you want to
be able to go somewhere and the and the
passengers are the employees and they're
excited not about the fuel in the car
how much fuel do we have no one gets
excited by that
we get excited where we're going
to Alaska are we near and it's and and
that's the analogy and when there's a
roadblock
if you're only driven by by the metrics
then the way we think about money the
way we think about corporate goals is
the same way we think about our goal is
to drive 200 miles a day our goal is to
make x amount of money right that's how
we think about it well what happens if
you drive 150 miles
is that a problem what happens if
there's a roadblock
do you know what to do you start
freaking out and panicking because
you're going to miss your numbers we're
Purpose Driven
companies that know their destinations
in the idealized state they take detours
and to the outside world that looks like
you're going sideways or slowly but you
know you're just going around
and that's how companies actually look
you know it's circuitous and messy and
purpose helps us keep focused on the
very far distant future so we know we're
going in the right vector
even if somebody can't tell we're going
the right direction and so people have
to understand the purpose of the goals
you're setting and how they're
contributing to something and start
talking like we an rpnl
I don't have the word profit on my p l
it doesn't exist
on my p l it says freedom
I damn well want more freedom this month
than I had last month
right freedom to say no to things that I
want to do
freedom to give it away freedom to take
care of my people
I want freedom because profit means
nothing so I'm trying to contextualize
all of these words that have no inherent
inherent magic to them
so yeah think of money like Fuel and
fuel drives your purpose be Purpose
Driven and talk about the place you're
trying to get to and talk about the
world that you imagine
and you damn well better make a lot of
fuel to get there because it's going to
be expensive and it's going to take a
long time